the prospect of being able to
manufacture Clips with AI and deep fakes
and that where it's going to be hard for
most people most of the time to even
figure out that the the whether they're
in the presence of something real
um you know forget about being divorced
from Context there was no context uh
I mean that is a that's a misinformation
apocalypse that is we are right on the
cusp of and you know it's
that's terrifying or it could be just a
new world like where Alice going to
Wonderland where humor is the only thing
we have and that will save us maybe in
the end Trump's approach to social media
was the right one after all nothing is
true and everything's absurd
yeah but we can't live that way people
function on the basis of what they
assume is true right they think you know
have functioned to do anything it's like
I mean you have to you have to know what
you think is going to happen or you have
to at least give a probabilistic waiting
over the future otherwise you're you're
going to be incapacitated by you're not
getting like people want certain things
and they have to have a rational plan to
get those desires gratified and they
don't want to die they don't want their
kids to die you tell them that there's a
comet hurtling toward Earth and they
should get outside and look up right
they're going to do it and if it turns
out it's misinformation you know it's
it's uh
it's going to matter because it comes
down to like what medicines do you give
your children right like we're going to
be manufacturing fake Journal articles I
mean this is I'm sure someone's using
chat GPT for for this you know as we
speak and
if it's not credible if it's not
persuasive now to most people
I mean honestly I don't think we're
gonna it's this I'll be amazed if it's a
year before we can actually create
Journal articles that would take you
know a a PhD to debunk
uh that are completely fake
um and they're people who are
celebrating this kind of
um
you know coming cataclysm but I just
it's just they're the people who
don't have anything to lose who are
celebrating it or just or so confused so
they just don't even know what's at
stake and then they're the people who
have met the few people
who we could count on a few hands who
have managed to insulate themselves or
at least imagine they've insulated
insulated themselves from the downside
here enough
that they're not implicated in the great
unraveling we are witnessing or could
could Witness